you have to tell me if something is true
a couple years ago an Oscar nomination
for moonlight yes and he's starting
rampage between Johnson yeah you're
still going strong in the Bond franchise
you decide I might be done with this
acting thing I'm going to give it all up
yeah I was having a moment as well I can
say understandably idea you can't on the
top of the world yeah but it was you
know I've been acting since I was nine
so I've like been in this profession
like 33 34 years now it's a it's a long
time and I think I was just burned out
basically and and also like moonlight
was an amazing experience but doing the
whole award season means that you do a
lot of things that really aren't about
what you love doing it's a lot of like
red carpet stuff and interview stuff and
you feel like a kind of you almost have
to perform yourself right and and so you
lose part of yourself I think and I just
felt really burned out so I thought I
want to do anything other than acting so
why this what brought you back to acting
like what was the problem I read this
movie I was eight months out of the
profession and I was like I said to my
team please don't contact me until the
year is over but eight months and they
were like we've got this project and we
think you should really read it and I
read it and I was on the edge of my seat
throughout and I had so much compassion
and admiration for this lead character
of Alicia that I play and I was like
this is the movie that I've got to come
back and do so and I'm so glad I did
because it has made a phenomenal movie
yeah and I mean it's gonna you know
raise some eyebrows and ruffle some
feathers like me with what it has to say
police brutality
original justice like what do you want
on just to take away from that aspect of
the movie I think the main message of
the movie is about being the change and
Alicia says it right at the end of the
movie she says you know and she she and
her whole journey really is about being
the change she's one person who decides
to stand up against corruption and
police brutality and expose that and if
everybody could try in their own small
way to be the change then that's I think
how we change the world to really
ultimately so I think it's
it's a hopeful message you know and
hopefully this film will encourage
dialogue about these important issues
that we're all facing at the moment yeah
is it true that your mom couldn't handle
this one my mum when halfway through the
movie she went and hid in the toilet and
called my brother and was like I can't
go and she was crying at the end she was
so emotional bless her she can't cope
with it any time her daughter is in
trouble she's like right over there she
can't just like I'm sitting right next
to you mom okay she was really upset cuz
she said thing why was nobody helping
you I know Mom it's a movie now just a
couple days ago we saw a headline that
you're having conversations about
something are we allowed to talk about
it at this point what we can say is that
I love the franchise and obviously I've
worked with Andy Serkis before and I've
worked with Woody Harrelson and I love
the two of them and so I'm in
discussions and I'm excited to be in
discussions nice and one last thing with
Phoebe Waldo bridge people are talking
about her she did the co-write for the
Bond movie and like that's the first
female that has co-written one of the
Bond movies you've been involved in so I
know you can't talk about what's in the
script what did her that female voice
bring to the blonde script well the
first thing to say about that is it and
is that Phoebe is not as such a kind of
a co-writer in the sense it was written
by and wade and Purvis who've done most
of the Bond movies up to this point and
then Cary Fukunaga our director also
wrote it and so Phoebe actually did the
dialogue pass to kind of bring out more
the female perspective and also to add a
bit of humor and so on to it and I think
she did a phenomenal job but you know I
don't know if she would take the title
co-writer
congratulations to me thank you very
much